Wednesday morning on Sunday the Pro Bowl
back here in Las Vegas and it's part of
a big football weekend here in town it's
gonna be huge you can watch all the
action and you can work on your chip
shot at the same time this morning we
welcome Lauren McGrady to the Good Day
Las Vegas team Lauren is live at Topgolf
this morning she's got Candace by her
side working on her shot over there too
and Lauren it looks like yours needs a
little work but welcome
yeah hey I I didn't preach to be any
good at sports we're good but we are
trying that's the important thing out
here but thank you so much for joining
us here and we are at Topgolf we've got
Mary LeBlanc once again Topgolf Las
Vegas Okay so
what is the game plan here we're talking
food we're talking it's not a party
without food what are some top things
people should order absolutely so we've
got our pretzel board and for the family
the injectable donut holes they come
with syringes with different flavors so
the kids can take them off and inject
them with whatever they want we've also
got platters and shareables so you can
create the mess and then leave it we'll
clean it yeah this is an Artistry right
here with the chartreuse yeah absolutely
it's so good no awesome and so when we
talk about you know Topgolf Las Vegas
all there is to offer here why is this
the place to be
so you've got golfing base so you can
watch the game and play yeah try that
you also have couches if you're not into
that you can rent a couch and hang out
in here this is the most popular spot in
the building and I mean the screens kind
of tell the story of themselves you were
saying you recommend reservations
absolutely so we do take reservations
for the big game as well as March Hoops
but you can find out all the info on
topgolf.com events perfect so lots of
things coming up as far as for this
weekend and also you know March Madness
coming too yes yeah we're prepared for
everything I mean you want a couch for I
don't know a random game in another
country like we'll turn it on for you
awesome thank you so much Mary well
we're going to keep it here uh maybe
we'll try to redeem ourselves with that
uh with the hits again but don't go
anywhere Candace Charles is back talking
money talking Sports bed so put your
money where your mouth is uh we're live
out here Lauren negretti 8 news now at
Topgolf oh I love it she said injectable
donut holes yeah that sounds like a
medical condition or also the tastiest
thing ever oh Lauren how look for us and
tell us how it is thank you welcome to
the team 5